ich möchte verstehen warum die Bahn so
schlecht funktioniert wie läuft's mit
der Bahn
[Musik]
jetzt hier freigegeben
fakt ist wollen wir unsere Klimaziele
erreichen müssen wir runter von der
Straße rein in die Bahn es geht darum
nachhaltige Lösungen für die
Mobilitätsbedürfnisse von morgen zu
entwickeln
als Alternative zum Auto wäre schon gut
dass sie pünktlich kommt die Bahn
faszinierendes Beispiel dafür was
modernste Eisenbahntechnik in
Deutschland leisten kann
[Musik]
wo sind die kreativen Lösungen für eine
klimafreundliche Verkehrspolitik
heute dann auch mehr
vom Auto aber so ist es halt schwierig
die Bahn könnte eine klimaheldin sein
doch was bremst die Bahn
[Musik]
Aktivistinnen von Greenpeace Regeln des
Verkehrsministerium in Berlin ab wie ein
Tatort
Greenpeace pocht auf das deutsche
Klimaschutzgesetz da steht drin bis 2030
müssen wir die CO2-Emissionen senken um
65% gegenüber 1990 wer Klimaschutzgesetz
bricht wer
Handlungsmacht hat und die nicht nutzt
der begeht klimaverbrechen das heißt in
Berlin im Ministerium sitzt derjenige
der mehr machen kann und aus ihrer Sicht
mehr machen muss wir machen muss das ist
nicht irgendwie eine freundliche
Aufforderung sondern das ist ein
Gesetzesbruch
schwere Vorwürfe der AktivistInnen
das Tempo muss anziehen soll der
Verkehrssektor die Klimaziele schaffen
müssten die Emissionen 14 Mal so schnell
sinken wie bisher
letztes Jahr wurde das co2-sparziel aber
im Gegenteil um 11 Millionen Tonnen
verfehlt ich habe auf jeden Fall
Verständnis für die Sorgen vor allen
Dingen junger Menschen dass das
Weltklima im Schieflage geraten ist und
deshalb arbeitet das Ministerium mit
Hochdruck daran dass diese Probleme
angepackt werden
die Probleme mit der Bahn sind
beträchtlich ein marodes Netz veraltete
Technik zu wenig Personal Michael teurer
und sein Chef Verkehrsminister Volker
Wissing wissen das längst
ich will diese Probleme angehen und
lösen indem ich sie zur chefsachen
machen
Chefsache also die Bahn muss zum
Rückgrat der Mobilität werden auch im
ländlichen Raum steht im
Koalitionsvertrag mein Deutschland ist
jetzt endlich ernst mit dem Klimazielen
die Bahn Offensive im Allgäu sieht
aktuell so aus
für den Weg zur Arbeit von Kaufbeuren
nach München nimmt Thorsten Krull immer
wenn es darauf ankommt das Auto nicht
die Bahn
so dass von zehn mal sechs Mal die Bahn
einfach den Anschluss nicht halten kann
oder zu spät kommt
das kannst du natürlich auch in der
Führungsposition nicht bringen das ist
ständig nicht da bist oder zu spät bist
sobald er morgens Termine hat ist alles
selbst das hier berechenbarer als die
Bahn
wir sind jetzt hier am Ende von der
Autobahn A96 und hier stehst du immer im
Stau in der Regel so 25 Minuten
die Wartezeiten hier sind natürlich
schon einen kalkuliert und ja Klima
mäßig ist es natürlich ein Horror
gut zehn Kilo CO2 haben wir gleich raus
geblasen auf den gut 90 Kilometern nach
München und theoretisch wäre die Bahn
schneller doch die Politik hat sie
kaputt gespart wollte sie fit machen für
die Börse nicht für die Zukunft man
könnte fast Verständnis haben für die
Probleme heute wenn du tagtäglich
draußen stehst und in den Hintern
abfrisst nein
dann hält das Verständnis sich sehen
es hakt an vielen Ecken zwar stellt das
Unternehmen regelmäßig neue
fahrgastrekorde auf doch das Netz ist
massiv überlastet auch weil seit der
Bahnreform 1994 mehr als 5.400 Kilometer
Bahnstrecken stillgelegt wurden
auch viele Bahnhöfe sind aufgegeben
heute quetschen sich immer mehr Züge auf
ein viel zu kleines Netz das führt zu
Stau und Verspätungen
im Fernverkehr dümpelt die Bahnen im
Schnitt bei 65% Pünktlichkeit ein
Negativrekord und für die Bahn gelten
Züge ja sogar dann als pünktlich wenn
Sie bis zu sechs Minuten zu spät kommen
ob dadurch Anschlüsse verpasst werden
oder nicht
es muss sich was tun so viel steht fest
Stefan Carsten forscht über Mobilität
und ist ein gefragter Ratgeber auch für
Wirtschaft und Politik um den
Klimawandel aufzuhalten um die
Verkehrswende zu schaffen brauchen wir
doch nur eine pünktliche verlässliche
Bahn was ist daran so schwer es ist
total einfach wir müssen diese
Entscheidung treffen dass wir die
Verkehrswende realisieren wollen und wir
müssen massiv wirklich massiv
entschieden Infrastruktur investieren
hier wurde massiv investiert vier
Milliarden Euro
ein Prestigeprojekt der Bahn wird nach
zwölf Jahren Bauzeit eingeweiht gut
[Musik]
die Neubaustrecke nach Ulm ist Teil der
geplanten Achse Paris Bratislava und
bekommt den göttlichen Segen
gepriesen seist du oh Gott der unser
Gebet erhört amen was kann die Bahn von
Jesus lernen sie kann von Jesus kann sie
lernen den Blick auf den Menschen zu
richten die Zeiten waren auch nicht
anders als Jesus gepredigt hat und er
war davon überzeugt das reicht Gottes
kommt und glauben Sie das reicht
zufriedener Mobilität kommt auch noch
für uns
dieses eine Leuchtturmprojekt der Region
bringt 15 Minuten Zeitgewinn solange das
zweite noch nicht fertig ist Stuttgart
21 dann soll es rund 30 Minuten
schneller gehen
[Musik]
die Zeremonie in Ulm beginnt zu Musik
von two steps from Hell zwei Schritte
entfernt von der Hölle
[Musik]
ich finde dass das bahnbashing aufhören
muss die Schiene ist ein toller
Verkehrsträger und vor dem Hintergrund
ist es ja so wichtig dass wir den
Sanierungsstau abbauen eine
Generalsanierung des Netzes vornehmen
aber auch
Kapazitätserweiterungen dann planen
es sind große Pläne die die Politik mit
der Bahn hat das ist gut doch die
Realität macht so manchen großen Plan
ein bisschen kleiner
auf einer neuen Strecke der deutschen
Bahnen Baden-Württemberg ist es gleich
am zweiten Tag zur Ausfällen gekommen
die Züge zwischen Wendlingen und Ulmen
müssen wieder über die alte Trasse
geführt werden so dass sich die Fahrzeit
mit unteren etwa eine Stunde verlängert
alle sind sich einig dass wir neu bei
Strecken brauchen damit die Bahn
wirklich schnell pünktlich und
zuverlässig wird aber geht das alles
schnell genug
60 km sind es von Wendlingen bis Ulm 60
von insgesamt 74 neu gebauten
Schienenkilometer 2022
dem Gegenüber wächst der Straßennetz in
Deutschland um rund 10.000 km jedes Jahr
[Musik]
fast 70% der pendler:innen in
Deutschland fahren mit dem Auto zu
arbeiten nur 13% nutzen öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel wie die Bahn
einer von ihnen ist Markus kühl guten
Morgen
ich muss mal für mich wenigstens eine
Fahrkarte kaufen du hast ja eine ja
richtig
aus Kaufbeuren muss er täglich grobe
Richtung gehen München ins kleine
Landsberg am Lech
gut 30 Kilometer fährt durch der Zug
nein ich muss oftmals zweimal umsteigen
ist wirklich Ärgerliche ist eben die
umsteigefreien Verbindungen zu unserem
wichtigsten Ziel hier nach München haben
sich in etwa halbiert das heißt
vergessen der ist erstmal abgesagt
Verkehrswende ist für Kaufbeuren
Ostallgäu abgesagt
Verkehrswende das sollte eigentlich
heißen weniger Autoverkehr mehr
klimaneutrale Mobilität mehr Bahn
für Markus aber bedeutet das heute 30
Kilometer drei Züge zweimal umsteigen
wie muss man gestrickt sein dass man
sich das jeden daran tut ja man muss
sehr sehr leidensfähig auf jeden Fall
sein oder Überzeugungstäter
Markus kühl ist beides in Kaufbeuren
macht der Politik für die Grünen ist
Umweltbeauftragter des Stadtrats und
fährt mit der guten alten Diesellok
mit Diesel fahren wir schon seit
Ewigkeiten wenn wir da wirklich was dran
ändern wollen was wir müssen dann müssen
wir in die Puschen kommen
erst 61% des Netzes in Deutschland sind
elektrifiziert pro Jahr wurden es
zuletzt im Schnitt 65 km mehr um das
Ziel der Bundesregierung bis 2030 zu
erreichen müssten es von nun an 500 km
im Jahr sein
Markus kühl blickt neidisch zu den
Nachbarn in die Schweiz sie haben halt
frühzeitig angefangen auf den
Verkehrsträger Bahn zu setzen und was
nicht außer Acht gelassen werden darf
ist die Schweiz hat keine
Automobilindustrie
keine Automobilindustrie ist es wirklich
so simpel
Tatsache ist die Schweiz ist Bahnland
durch und durch
[Musik]
in der Leitstelle der SBB in Bern
erzählt ein stolzer Bahnmanager von
einem Erfolgsmodell
das ist der Basel hier und dann geht es
hier in die nach unten und weiter und
Sie sehen da wenn es da eine Plus hat
hinten das ist der Zug etwas verspätet
und wenn nicht steht dann sind die Züge
pünktlich unterwegs und heute morgen ist
ein sehr zuverlässig gute morgen da
haben wir sind eigentlich alle Züge auf
dem Strich also Minuten genau unterwegs
und was ist jetzt 9 6 4 6 Minuten plus
da wird der Schweiz
mehr als 3 Minuten Verspätung hat bei
uns auf und da muss man dann eben
schauen wie groß die Auswirkungen sind
manches kann man lernen von der kleinen
Schweiz große Probleme entstehen erst
gar nicht wenn man sie löst solange sie
noch kleine Probleme sind
sind an allen großen
Knotenpunkten haben wir sogenannte
dispozüge die sind besetzt mit
lockpersonal und
kundenbegleitpersonal die wir dann auch
einschießen können um die Verspätung an
einem Knotenpunkt aufzufangen und mit
einem pünktlichen Zug weiter zu fahren
eigentlich sind die bereit wie die
Feuerwehr und das führt dazu dass wir
nicht diesen Dominoeffekt haben sondern
dass er dann die Kunden eben ab diesem
Punkt wo wir reinschießen wieder
pünktlich pünktlich reisen können
klar das Warnitz in der Schweiz das
ganze System Bahn ist hier etwa zehn Mal
kleiner als in Deutschland
verblüffend ist es trotzdem die Züge
fahren zu über 92% dann waren sie sollen
die Bahn kommt in der Schweiz stimmt das
wirklich
man sagt er nicht umsonst die Schweizer
ticken wie ihre Uhren also sind eben
auch sehr pünktlich und da ist jeder
Schweiz ein bisschen stolz darauf und
wir haben seit jeher eine sehr großen
Rückhalt im Bevölkerung und Politik
der Effekt ist offensichtlich für rund
28 Prozent aller Wege nutzen die
Menschen in der Schweiz öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel in Deutschland sind es
nur gut 14 Prozent
das kann die Deutsche Bahn was kann die
Bahn von der Schweiz lernen
die Schweiz ist insofern mit Deutschland
nicht zu vergleichen als die Schweiz
seit vielen Jahren pro Einwohner etwa
400 € pro Jahr in die Schiene steckt in
Deutschland
hat es seit in den vergangenen Jahren
etwa 60 Euro in die Schiene gesetzt wir
haben als Ampelkoalition das jetzt
verdoppelt auf 124 Euro aber richtig ist
die Schweiz haben durch massive
Investitionen in eine leistungsfähige
Infrastruktur die Grundlage dafür
geschaffen dass ein attraktives Angebot
mit einem integralen Taktfahrplan
gefahren werden kann und wir haben uns
ja die Schweiz in Deutschland zum
Vorbild genommen
ein
unvergleichbares Vorbild
Taktfahrplan das heißt viele Züge viele
Anschlüsse kurze Wartezeiten überall in
der Schweiz machen sie das seit 1982 das
dieser tagfahrplan klappt braucht es
eine sehr sehr präzise Planung und viel
viel
Orientierung dass man diesen tagfahrplan
dann auch realisieren kann das heißt die
Politiker muss wollen das heißt das
Unternehmen muss wollen und das heißt es
muss auch von den Kunden verstanden
werden welche Vorteile ein tagfahrplan
mit sich bringt und welche Vorteile
bringt damit sich bei uns kommen alle
Züge zur vollen Stunde als Beispiel in
den Knoten hinein warten dann dort um
alle in alle Richtungen die Anschlüsse
sicher zu stellen und gehen dann wieder
hinaus das heißt heute als Berufspendler
brauche ich nicht mehr in den Fahrplan
nachzuschauen sondern ich weiß ganz
genau um halb fährt mein Zug von Bern
nach Zürich und das jeden Tag zu jeder
Uhrzeit
sowas wollen wir eigentlich auch den
deutschlandtakt ab 2030 die große
Koalition hatte ihn bereits 2018 als die
Revolution ausgerufen
von Wismar nach Trier von Cottbus nach
Aachen jede Stunde ein Zug schnelle
Verbindung umsteigen ohne langes Warten
direkte busanschlüsse im ländlichen Raum
dafür bräuchte es von allem mehr Züge
moderne Bahnstrecken Personal das hat
die Vorgängerregierung schon begonnen so
dass wir sagen in den nächsten 50 Jahren
als Jahrhundertprojekt will man ein
integralen Taktfahrplan in Deutschland
umsetzen und es ist notwendig um die
Klimaziele zu erreichen jetzt sagen Sie
deutschland hat in 50 Jahren
die Vorgängerregierung hat immer noch
vom Deutschlandtag 2030 gesprochen und
sie haben offenbar jetzt
eingesehen dass das eine Vision ist oder
der Deutschland Takt erfordert ja
Investitionen in zweistelliger
Milliardenhöhe also wir gehen davon etwa
50 bis 60 Milliarden Euro aus und da ist
es völlig klar und da war es auch immer
klar dass das Jahrzehnte dauert
[Musik]
50 Jahre nun also Deutschland hat 2017
die Klimaziele werden wir so verfehlen
die Bahn bleibt aus dem Takt die Schweiz
zeigt jetzt das Stoppschild für deutsche
ICE die bisher bis in die alten fuhren
bei uns sind die internationalen Züge in
den Taktverkehr eingegliedert das heißt
der Zug der von Deutschland von Hamburg
kommt macht bei uns dann eben einen Teil
dieses taktfahrplanes aus und da haben
wir jetzt auch aufgrund von
Schwierigkeiten und Verspätungen haben
wir gewisse Züge an der an der Grenze
gesprochen damit wir da national unsere
unsere Zuverlässigkeit weiter
sicherstellen kann man kann also sagen
die Deutschen waren zu unpünktlich und
sie wollten sich nicht weiter ihren Takt
durcheinander bringen lassen ja wir
haben einfach geschaut dass wir für die
nationalen Kunden eine gute zuverlässige
Lösungen bringen können
gute zuverlässige Lösungen heute jetzt
hier bei der Deutschen Bahn hätten sie
die gerne
in die Schweiz schauen denn in dem Land
ist es ja vor vielen Jahrzehnten schon
Konsens gewesen dass man auf die Schiene
setzt aber ich erkenne auch ein
Umsteuern in der Politik schon seit
Jahren deswegen ist die finanzielle
Ausstattung jetzt so dass wir den
instandhaltungsrückstand auch wirklich
abbauen können
8,9 Milliarden Euro pumpt der Bund
dieses Jahr in die Schiene sogar etwas
mehr als in die Straße die Politik
verkauft das als richtungsweisend
allerdings für Land und Dorfstraßen
bezahlen Länder und Kommunen weitere
Milliarden
für die Bahn zahlt nur der Bund und ob
das Geld reicht daran hat inak Ferlemann
große Zweifel er war in der großen
Koalition für die Bahn verantwortlich
die ampelregierung hat seine alte
Finanzplanung im Wesentlichen einfach
übernommen
das hat sich natürlich jetzt alles
deutlich verändert und vor allem durch
die unglaublichen Steigerungen die wir
bei den Baupreisen bei dem Baukosten
haben und dann schreibt man aus und
stellt man fest dass man eben zum Teil
10 15 bei manchen Gewerken sogar 30
prozentige Kostensteigerung hat dazu
kommt jetzt die nächsten Jahre ja noch
die deutlich ansteigende Inflation das
heißt diese etas reichen um Längen nicht
mehr aus um die Bahn so zu ertüchtigen
wie wir das uns alle gemeinsam
vorstellen man hätte einen viel größeren
Schluck aus der Pole nehmen müssen
12 Jahre lag die Zukunft der Bahn in den
Händen von cdu/csu aktuell streitet die
Ampel über die Verkehrswende und der
Sanierungsfall bahnfeld der FDP zu
es laufen ja gerade in der Koalition
Gespräche über die künftige Finanzierung
und ich gehe davon aus dass es gelingt
nennenswerte zusätzliche Beträge zu
mobilisieren die Kritik der cdu/csu kann
ich allerdings nicht nachvollziehen da
ja die cdu/csu hier dieses Haus und auch
die Infrastruktur nicht in tademlosen
Zustand übergeben hat und da kommt
eigentlich so eine Kritik jetzt fast
einer retrograden Amnesie gleich
[Musik]
nun also ist die FDP zuständig für die
Verkehrswende und mahnt beharrlich zu
deutlicher Einschnitte beim Auto würden
der deutschen Wirtschaft Schaden und
damit uns allen der Dauerstreit mit den
Grünen
noch arrangieren wir uns in Deutschland
offenbar mit einer Bahn von gestern
[Applaus]
letztes Mal umsteigen für Markus kühl
seine grünen Regieren in Berlin zwar mit
aber eben nicht im Verkehrsministerium
Zwiespalt ja man ist ja mit in
Regierungsverantwortung mit einem
Koalitionspartner FDP und der aber
leider nicht in unserem Sinne die
richtigen Schritte in die Wege leitet
ich würde mir tatsächlich einen anderen
Verkehrsminister wünschen
der die Sachen tatsächlich erkennt
und umsetzt in Sachen Verkehrswende sehr
viel Geld natürlich kostet viel Geld das
ist gar keine Frage aber bei
Straßenbauprojekten da fragt auch
niemand nach dem Geld
[Musik]
dies ist keine bahnbaustelle hier wird
die höchst umstrittene A100 gebaut
mitten durch Berlin
Bauabschnitt 16
700 Millionen Euro für 3,5 km
umgerechnet sind das 200.000 € pro Meter
die A100 wird die teuerste Autobahn
Deutschlands
das ist eine Fortsetzung der
Verkehrspolitik der letzten 60 Jahre es
ist ein Stillstand ich kenne keine Stadt
in Europa wo heute noch Autobahnen
gebaut werden keine in überall wird in
Fahrradwege investiert überall wird in
eine Ausbau von ÖPNV und von Schienen
investiert nur in Deutschland wird Beton
verbaut für Autos verpennt Deutschland
hier gerade die Zukunft definitiv ja das
ist ein Standort Nachteil für Berlin und
für Deutschland was wir hier sehen ich
glaube wir brauchen tatsächlich eine
eine viel stärkere Priorisierung der
Schiene
genau das aber will die FDP offenbar
nicht
auf Druck der Liberalen hat der
Bundestag beschlossen auch
Straßenbauprojekte sollen beschleunigt
werden
ist es da wieder das Autoland
Deutschland
[Musik]
die Verkehrswende und der Weg dahin sind
umstritten fakt ist wir müssen massiv
CO2 einsparen sind auf klimafreundliche
Mobilität angewiesen
es fällt auf die Bahn war jahrzehntelang
das Stiefkind der Politik
Deutschland denkt eben sehr stark vom
Auto her also man hat zum Beispiel
Flughäfen geplant die direkt an
Autobahnen liegen man hat aber gar nicht
an die Schiene gedacht weil das war
unmodern geworden schauen sich mal die
vielen Gewerbegebiete an die rechts und
links der großen Autobahn liegen da
werden sie kein Bahnanschluss finden
aber der Autobahnanschluss der ist
natürlich da
vielleicht müssen wir das Denken
verändern
und vielleicht müssen wir für das
Umdenken bessere Anreize schaffen
die Pendlerpauschale die das Dienstwagen
Privileg die diese Subventionierung
alleine machen schon 15 Milliarden 16
Milliarden Euro im Jahr an politischer
Subventionierung für das Auto aus ein
gratis ÖPNV in Deutschland würde den
Steuerzahler wahrscheinlich so zwischen
15 bis 20 Milliarden kosten das heißt
wenn man das mal vergleicht hat man im
Grunde genommen eine eine Party eine
gleiches Verhältnis die Verkehrswende
scheitert nicht an den Kosten sondern
sie scheitert an dem Willen der
Politikerinnen und Politiker
im Ministerium heißt es dazu alle
umweltschädlichen Subventionen kommen
auf den Prüfstand unabhängig davon
setzen der Minister und seine FDP weiter
auch aufs Auto
dabei liegen die Treibhausgasemissionen
im Schienenverkehr satte
57%. unter dem PKW
glaubst du gerade die jungen deine
Generation würden auch wegen des Klimas
sehr gerne mehr Bahn fahren da bin ich
mir sehr sicher ja also gerade meine
Generation glaube ich der dass sie dafür
bereit sind das Auto öfter mal stehen zu
lassen und definitiv mehr Bahn fahren
wollen
knapp drei Viertel der 16 bis
29-Jährigen sind überzeugt ein besserer
öffentlicher Nahverkehr könnte die
Klimabelastung wesentlich reduzieren wie
viel kommt im Moment schon an bei euch
von der Verkehrswende
relativ wenig muss man schon so deutlich
sagen und so ein fortgeschrittenes Land
wie Deutschland ist das sah immer noch
nicht geschafft wurde die die Bahn
ordentlich auszubauen gibt einem schon
zu denken finde ich
fest steht wir sind auf die Bahn
angewiesen sie könnte eine echte
klimarerin sein dafür aber müsste sie
verlässlich funktionieren
und wirklich alle müssten sie einfach
nutzen können
hier steht we love neun Euro das 9 Euro
Ticket aus dem letzten Sommer war das
eine gute Idee das war eine fantastische
Idee es haben wahnsinnig viele Menschen
zum ersten Mal erlebt wie es ist wenn
sie sich Mobilität leisten können also
für ganz ganz viele arme Menschen war
das ein Sommer von unfassbarer Freiheit
Mobilität klimafreundlich für alle
bezahlbar das war die Idee
in Berlin gibt es seither das sogenannte
29 euro-ticket gültig nur im Berliner
Stadtgebiet
die Aktion hat maßgeblich dazu
beigetragen dass die BVG inzwischen Abo
Millionärin ist die Zahl der Abonnements
stieg um 20% auf über eine Million
im Mai kommt dann das bundesweite
teurere Ticket
das 49 euro-ticket wird keinen Beitrag
zur Verkehrswende leisten in einer Stadt
wie Berlin müsste ich glaube ich 17 Mal
im Monat mit dem ÖPNV fahren damit sich
die 49 Euro für mich lohnen das heißt
die Menschen fangen jetzt an zu rechnen
zu kalkulieren brauche ich das lohnt
sich das überhaupt und viele werden bei
ihrem angestammten Mobilitätsverhalten
bleiben
dabei ist der Preis nur ein Aspekt von
mehreren
ich weiß nicht ob wir öfter Bahn fahren
nein zum ersten Mal seit fünf Jahren
wieder soll ich einen PKW abholen muss
warum holte die neuen PKW sie können
doch öfter Bahn fahren ich brauche nicht
wohne derzeit so dass ich keine
bahnausfluss habe also da wo ich wohne
braucht zum PKWs geht nicht anders
Landsberg Lech nach 40 Minuten ist
Markus kühl mit seinem diesel-zug
angekommen
Politik ist kompliziert das weiß er als
grüner aber es müsste trotzdem endlich
vorwärts gehen wer zuständig ist ist dem
Fahrgast egal sie müssen sich an einen
Tisch setzen ein Gesamtkonzept aus
arbeiten wenn das Angebot stimmt dann
kommen auf die Frage Gäste da bin ich
überzeugt
das ist die Vision eine Bahn mit der wir
gerne fahren
Aufmerksamkeit aufgrund einer
angesprochenen Brandmeldeanlage ist es
notwendig dass die Reisenden die Wagen
sieben sechs und fünf verlassen
keine pannenbahn sondern moderne
pünktliche Züge und schnelle
Verbindungen
in Deutschland klingt das immer noch wie
ein Märchen
sind wir enttäuscht davon sehr weil ich
würde die Bahn ja gerne nutzen und werde
im Prinzip mehr oder weniger gezwungen
aufs Auto wieder umzusteigen
jetzt bräuchte es Mut und Haltung die
Politik müsste viel Geld investieren und
unbequeme Entscheidungen treffen
das alles heute für die Bahn von
übermorgen
[Musik]